the man in a hurry he's got a lot to do
his audience awaits they're expecting
him to deliver the prime minister
telling them what they want to hear he's
going to deliver brexit and beat labour
in a general election we are coming out
of the EU on October the 31st come what
may
Cobras let's get Bret [ __ ] done we can
we must own we will and then let's get
ready to make our case to the country
against the factory so I'll anti-semitic
Marxist who are in Brighton last week
but if this crowd expected tough talk
for Europe they may have been surprised
today his tone conciliatory we are
European we love Europe
I love Europe anyway I love it we must
have a new relationship with the EU a
positive and confident partnership he
really wants a deal and his plan to get
one sent to Brussels today in Brussels
we are taping what I believe are
constructive and reasonable proposals
his proposal to abolish the current
backstop and replace it with a mixture
of checks at ports on the Irish Sea and
away from the border in Ireland yes this
is a compromise by the UK and I hope
very much that our friends understand
that and compromise in their turn but if
that doesn't fly in Brussels there's
another alternative arrangement the
alternative is no deal are we ready for
it yes we are are we determined to
resolve this yes we are supported here
and closer to home - I had kept my ace
up my sleeve my mother voted leave
I didn't know that says dad but Breck's
it's not enough their other policy boxes
to tick we will build 40 new hospitals
who will solve the problems of social
gap we're recruiting 20,000 police
officers every kid in the country a
superb education we are going to have a
battery a battery gigafactory there are
obstacles to overcome not least the
House of Commons if Parliament were a
reality TV show then the whole lot of us
I'm afraid would have been voted out of
the jungle by now but at least we'd have
had the consolation of watching the
speaker being forced to eat a kangaroo
testicle making them laugh but firing
them up too if Jeremy Corbyn were
allowed into Downing Street he will walk
up your taxes he would foul up the
economy he would rip up the alliance
between Britain and the United States
and he would break up the United Kingdom
we cannot allow it to happen before he
takes on labour in an election he has
won keep job to do the writing is on the
wall
let's get brexit done and let's bring
this country together thank you
chives at Jeremy Corbyn and a clear
message to the conference hall that
there will be no delay on brexit he's
delighted for bass here but this wasn't
just about Brussels or brexit this was a
speech about domestic policy - about
education the NHS the police because
this isn't just a rallying call for the
Conservatives that is his election
manifesto his cabinet knows he's got no
time to waste and breaks it at Christmas
so get it done on the 31st of October
and then look at the other challenges
but we expect there to be an election
and he was setting out a stall as to
what that election our election promises
and manifesto are going to be I think
people know that's coming but but
actually the big slogan rightly of
conferences get brexit done these lot
don't need convincing they're sold on
Boris Johnson the pitch popular here but
how will it go down impresses bathra P
Sky News Manchester